hello welcome to this video calling gah
and sindhu opponent and I guess yeah to
work hard to get back to 2400 maybe I
should check a new line against the
Trump I mean this is really okay but it
is not very very interesting there was
his recent game Giri with lucky against
them Caruana Giri had a very nice
position down really like that many
black has just no problems at all and
it's said it's not super exciting yeah
might night you might go from 95 so
getting rid of that slide the exposed
bishop
and paint that pin is something that I
cannot stay in all the time
yeah so I cut his bishop pair into and
again no problems whatsoever but not
much going on that's an I am I can shake
if I know this name oh my god Satya
peigans my young zoo oh my god whose
names are difficult okay so and he
decided to play it simple the other said
it's that's not a super exciting line
okay let's can I get somewhere here on
the print side probably not okay III at
least is attacked no he goes back it
looks like it feels a little bit like
progress okay um but anyway now you
might have go for c4 let's try to
prevent it wow it just gives me what why
is he doing that and without any thought
this is it so what's a big point here
but he basically claims that my night is
bad there ok he gets b7 that is the
thing and okay yeah my pieces at the
moment are not so coordinated that's
definitely true I once saw a tag f7 here
Oh
my night is terribly off there turb the
offside
I already tricky tricky to play without
losing one of the pieces I should have
thought about that a little bit before i
go into it if it wasn't necessary at all
there were many simple options with like
being okay okay if if i get a little bit
more time here I'm my night is terrible
see five I guess not doing it
now maybe just maybe just five now I can
take an f6 it should work see what is he
doing night discoveries currently I'm
covering this
I get my stuff coordinated I'm going
okay really okay but i'm not sure if i
manage check so I'm losing the exchange
because it's got Queen at five okay
check
check
time warning
still have some chances for fortress I
mean not if you place it right i guess
but cannot expect that all of the time
that they play it perfectly
and then finally bloody porno it was now
I don't know if he could have even shown
that if I don't blunder the porn and I
know he's blundering again and probably
would still win because I still have
issues here I cannot easily go up
because he invades himself 18 seconds
to go e form and it's always tricky
check I cannot completely pre move here
because of the damn promotion and I did
give him this I don't believe this
nonsense check I'm not I'm such an idiot
I'm such an idiot how can I just this
gala for offense on time oh I mean what
what does the only need to do that I win
I just I just have to go back here just
go back and pick up all the pawns I've
got five seconds I know what still it's
just so easy I mean it does everything
here to give me that game and I don't
take it anyway ok this is this is
probably not so great iso file remark
whether it took him two seconds to
figure that out but ok anyway yeah this
is good for wide I guess at least though
it's it's very difficult to play yeah
but I have to go here I guess and then
I'm okay not not blundering stuff chan
chan yeah now get to this which is
probably winning for Wyatt if he plays
it Roy
but Jan if i uncheck give them this yeah
this is just ridiculous p 6 just just
crazy Queen a 3 everything witness b6 is
just a joke over moon yeah I know I
should win Chang and I mean it was was
very easily winning just that was okay I
just have to go over here and pick up
the pawns it's it's super easy to care
for seconds at it it gets rational
unfortunately I can still do here and
and win but anyway anyway wow thanks for
watching